well the prime minister now says the
data implies
that the reopening has to be delayed but
here's what he said just a couple of
weeks ago
i can see nothing uh in the data at the
moment
that uh means we can't go ahead with
step four
or the the opening on june the 21st
so that was the prime minister on the
2nd of june but here's the thing let's
look at what the data was actually
saying then and look at whether it's
changed
since so there it is that's that's case
growth across the uk logarithmic charts
so
the steeper the line the higher the
growth rate and you can see look nothing
in the data back then it wasn't the
first time he had said it he also said
it on the 21st of may he also said it
was rather one of his colleagues in
downing street
said it on the second seventh of june
but look at that look at that line it's
pretty much the same uh now as it was
back
uh at the start of this month in other
words nothing really has changed we're
still heading where we were for a while
uh which is up potentially towards 30
000 cases
uh by july that's not news we've known
that for quite some time
and similarly when you look at the
indian variant of course a lot of people
talking about this indian this delta
variant
as being a cause for concern it clearly
is but it has been for some time this
just shows you the growth rate of it
going all the way back
uh to early may there is nothing in the
data on the 21st of may but in fact it
was growing at the same rate that it is
recently nothing in the data on the
second of june but growing at the same
rate that it is recently so again
nothing has really changed there
potentially hospitalizations they have
worse and they've started to pick up
this is the the line showing your
hospitalizations
and you can see again second of june
talking about nothing in the data and
they have accelerated since then but
worth just bearing in mind on the
seventh
uh downing street was still saying
nothing in the data but let's also take
a step back and remember
that when this reopening plan the
timetable was announced we got this
chart showing you what
could happen uh in a few different
scenarios uh if there were to be second
or indeed third surges
of this virus and just look at what's
actually happened look at those dots on
the left-hand side traveling traveling
traveling
that's what's actually happened so they
are a lot lower than many people
expected more or less in line in fact
with the best case scenario now they
could go up but of course that's where
we are
uh right now but there are these four
tests but it seems like we now have
another one which is
a target to get vaccinations up that's
the plan to try and
delay uh this lockdown ending in order
to get that
kind of bar up this shows you total
vaccinations so those who have been
had two doses up from about 30 million
at the moment to potentially 40 million
if it continues in line with
how it has done uh recently by the 19th
of july
and that would be if uk gets a
percentage of over 18 population uh
around the uk about 75 percent
of adults so the prime minister talking
about getting to 230 might get up to
three quarters
uh if it continues like that as a
proportion of the total population
more or less uh 60 so one and three
is that herd immunity or not we don't
really know but that does seem to be
the new target